we all know how the us fire the
manhattan project came to create the
world's first nuclear weapons
and how the ussr via espionage in its
own program of reverse engineering
managed to build its own bomb four years
later
but the third nation to create an atomic
weapon was britain and something not
often discussed is the means in which it
achieved this
so how did it how did britain get hold
of nuclear weapons and why did it feel
the need to have them
so britain was one of the first nations
to research the feasibility of nuclear
weapons and had its own independent
weapons program called the tube alloys
program
when the united states joined world war
ii britain agreed to give it all of the
information it had gathered on
developing nuclear weapons
in 1943 both the us and uk agreed to
share all knowledge concerning the
creation of atomic weapons
and as such you'd naturally assume that
britain would also have access to all of
the data and know-how from the manhattan
project but fun fact
no you see the us government after it
became clear that atomic weapons were
feasible wanted to maintain a monopoly
on these for as long as possible
the brits took this news poorly and saw
it as a bit of a betrayal whereas for
the us it was just politics
whilst the two were still allies there
were some concerns that britain in order
to maintain its crumbling empire may
consider pursuing an independent foreign
policy from the u.s
and adding nuclear weapons to that mix
was a no-no so when the u.s cut off
british access in 1946 britain was run
by clement atlee
whom the us government assumed would
adopt a semi-pacifist foreign policy
and given the state of britain's
finances wouldn't pursue the creation of
nuclear weapons
but they were wrong you see atlee was a
firm pragmatist when it came to foreign
policy and he knew that if britain was
to maintain any international relevance
whatsoever
it needed its own nuclear arsenal atli
was also concerned that the u.s would
return to its previous position of
isolationism and just leave europe to it
and so in 1947 ali authorized the
creation of a nuclear program at very
considerable cost to the country
the project code-named high-explosive
research to really throw off anyone
looking for a secret nuclear program was
centered in order shot
and it only took five years to build its
first nuclear weapon and it was done so
quickly because british scientists had
already worked on the manhattan project
and so it was just a case of continuing
their research to its logical conclusion
the us also did little to dissuade
britain from building nukes because
britain had a trump card
it controlled most of the world's
uranium supply at this point and had
agreed to share it with the us
that said the americans didn't share
much information with the uk during the
development of his weapons program
and a lot of this came from the fact
that there were numerous incidents of
british
scientists being soviet spies and so
obviously the us didn't wish to share
any secrets
originally britain had hoped to beat the
ussr to the punch but when the soviets
tested their own weapon in 1949 it was
seen as a monumental embarrassment
so having developed a weapon the next
issue was where it was to be tested
as any map will tell you britain is not
exactly a spacious place and one which
is densely populated
and so the british government looked to
its imperial territories for testing and
settled on australia now you might be
wondering why australia agreed to be
newt and there are several reasons
the first is that australia was a colony
and colonies don't generally get
opinions on things that affect them
and the second reason is that britain
promised to aid australia in the
creation of civilian nuclear power in
return
the first test operation hurricane was
carried out in 1952 and it was a success
by 1955 britain's nuclear deterrent was
fully operational with roughly 15 bombs
at its disposal
three years later the us allowed for
britain to collaborate on nuclear
weapons again and britain was firmly
established as the world's third nuclear
power
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons james bissonette
sam kelly money maker the pastry section
danny maloney
moe marvin cassell rob waterhouse james
castaneda jordan longley spinning three
plates gustav swann jerry landon rasheed
ali marcus asner izzy
maggie paxkowski cooling castleman david
silverman coppertone anthony beckett
matthew shipley
lexy schwinn robert wetzel skye
chappelle winston caywood aaron the
white spencer lightfoot and fobo joe